look hello hi I'm Lucifer oh you've got
nintend's name I'm not the best with
First Impressions and I get a bit
anxious in new environments but if you
give me treats you'll have my heart well
you're in luck she went for the trees
good move good move feisty on the
outside snuggle bug on the inside I'll
be by your side day and night but touch
is not my love language me neither wait
look you see this you don't know this is
not a good sign you don't like me since
he doesn't want to be with me like I
want to win his affection I think the
owner is maybe female they seem like a
like a calm person she got a nice chunky
belly I like that I could see myself
having fun with him I really want him to
like me